here's a pro tip don't ask to go on
vacation in jamaica if you're on trial
for storming the capital in one of the
funniest minute orders ever well here
i'll just read it to you this is
straight from the judge defendant while
on pre-trial release and facing charges
including a serious fell on the offense
stemming from his alleged actions on
january 6 2021 wishes to leave the
michigan winter to spend 10 days in the
warmer climes of jamaica to meet the
family of a woman with whom defendant
has been in a committed relationship
although such a meeting may be an
important step in defendant's personal
relationship defendants surrendered his
entitlement to unfettered international
travel when also quote he allegedly
announced his intent to quote storm the
swamp and one week later on january 6
2021 followed through by joining a mob
at the capitol that in his words took
that building an event he allegedly
viewed as the proudest day of his life
this court will not commemorate the
one-year anniversary of this attack on
the capital by granting defendant's
request for non-essential foreign travel
signed by chief judge beryl a howell
dang